vous en foutez de la dissertation de
français c'est ce que me disaient mes
amis de maths sup
quand j'étais moi en prépa hec ça arrive
vous êtes en prépa scientifique et puis
le coefficient de la dissertation de
français est faible au concours des
écoles d'ingénieurs donc oui logiquement
vous ne devez pas y consacrer beaucoup
de temps mais il y a une opportunité
comme le français n'est pas le point
fort des candidats et qu'en plus il
néglige la matière et bien c'est facile
de sortir du lot
[Musique]
c'est facile à deux conditions premières
conditions vous devez connaître les
règles du jeu c'est à dire que vous
devez savoir précisément ce que vous
pouvez faire et ce que vous ne pouvez
pas faire pour décrocher une bonne note
c'est ce dont je vais vous parler dans
cette vidéo je vais vous dire tout ce
que vous devez savoir pour réussir la
dissertation français en prépa
scientifique je vais d'abord vous dire
ce que vous devez savoir sur l'épreuve
ensuite ce que vous devez savoir sur les
sujets et enfin sur les notes et sur les
statistiques des différents concours
maintenant qu'elle est la seconde
condition pour sortir du lot en français
c'est que vous devez maîtriser la
méthodologie de la dissertation parce
que c'est vraiment important pour les
correcteurs de cette épreuve
ça tombe bien j'ai ce qu'il vous faut
profiter de mon cours gratuits de la
méthodologie de la dissertation vous
pouvez vous y inscrire soit en cliquant
sur le lien qui apparaît maintenant en
haut à droite de la vidéo soit en
cliquant sur celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo
les élèves de prépa scientifique
l'adorent donc je sais que vous ne serez
pas déçu mais bon
vous n'êtes pas là pour je vous parle de
méthodes haut que devez-vous savoir sur
les dissertations de français pour
réussir vos concours
[Musique]
cette épreuve je la connais bien parce
que j prépare des élèves depuis
maintenant plus de 10 ans je me souviens
par exemple d'adrien que j'ai formés à
ma méthodologie de la dissertation et
qui a intégré polytechnique l'école de
ses rêves
mais assez parlé de moi alors vous le
savez probablement déjà mais la
dissertation et la première épreuve de
français aux concours des écoles
d'ingénieurs elle est parfois accompagné
d'une épreuve de résumer comme à la
centrale par exemple dans cette vidéo je
ne vais parler que de la dissertation
d'accord comme vous êtes des
scientifiques je vais commencer avec
quelques chiffres que vous devez
connaître le coefficient de cette
épreuve c'est 8% ce qui veut dire que 13
points en français vous feront gagner un
seul point de moyenne générale
je sais c'est pas fou second chiffre
important l'épreuve dure quatre heures
pour certaines écoles le nes paris lyon
et cachant bien sûr polytechnique mais
elle dure trois heures pour d'autres
écoles comme l'y mines ponts et lorsque
les preuves mail un résumé et une
dissertation ou un résumé des questions
et une dissertation
dans ces cas là vous devez consacrer au
moins 2 heures à la dissertation
cette information est importante parce
qu'elle implique que vous devez adapter
votre méthode à la durée de l'épreuve
et ça vous ne devez pas vous en rendre
compte le jour j vous devez vous calibré
par essais et erreurs tout au long de
l'année
maintenant qu'est ce que vous devez
savoir sur l'exercice lui-même première
chose c'est une dissertation il s'agit
donc de réfléchir d'argumenter et de
bien dit j'ai le but n'est pas de
montrer que vous connaissez votre cours
regardez ce que dit le rapport de jury
de centrale supélec de 2004 comme
d'autres années on déplorera des erreurs
méthodologiques trop répandue pour ne
pas devenir irritante donc encore une
fois je vous invite à vous inscrire pour
recevoir mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie de la dissertation
voilà je ne vous en dit pas plus sur
l'exercice de la dissertation parce que
j'ai déjà publié
vidéo à ce sujet elle s'intitule qu'est
ce qu'une dissertation vous la trouverez
facilement sur cette chaîne youtube
seconde chose que vous devez savoir à
propos de la dissertation de français
dans votre copine vous êtes obligé de
prendre appui sur les oeuvres du
programme de l'année votre dissertation
doit apporter la preuve que vous
connaissez ses oeuvres dans le détail
regardez ce que dit le rapport de jurys
des ccp de 2010 c'est dans le manque de
contacts individuels avec les textes au
programme que récit de la faiblesse est
essentielle de l'exercice dans la
plupart des copies beaucoup de
candidates donne l'impression de n'avoir
pas lu vraiment les trois oeuvres le
crayon à la main ce qui constitue tout
de même la condition absolument
nécessaire pour pouvoir en parler alors
ça ne veut pas dire que vous devez
vraiment lire les trois oeuvres crayon à
la main
ça veut dire que c'est l'impression que
vous devez donner dans votre copie j'en
ai terminé avec ce que vous devez savoir
sur l'épreuve
maintenant je vais vous parler des
sujets
[Musique]
vous allez devenir des ingénieurs donc
vous êtes pragmatique commençons par
regarder les sujets qui sont tombés on
va regarder ceux qui sont tombés à
polytechnique younès amine pont à
centrale et au ccp
voici le sujet tombé à polytechnique
johannes en 2020 voici le sujet tomber
aux mille ponthou jour en 2020
voici le sujet tombé à centrale et enfin
voici le sujet tout mais au ccp
alors qu'est ce que vous devez savoir à
propos des sujets vous devez retenir
trois choses la première c'est que ce
sont toujours des citations ce ne sont
pas des citations des oeuvres au
programme et parfois le sujet ne précise
pas le nom de l'auteur
c'est important que vous gardiez à
l'esprit que le sujet sur invitation
parce qu'on traite pas de la même
manière un sujet
citation est un sujet qui consiste en
une question ou encore en une locution
donc vous vous devez acquérir une
méthodologie de la dissertation adapté
aux sujets citation deuxième chose que
vous devez retenir à propos des sujets
les citations peuvent être longues
la citation du sujet de polytechnique de
2020 fait 46 morts
ce qui est très long pour une phrase
celle du sujet de mines ponts fait 45 mo
c'est pareil c'est très long en plus ce
sont des phrases compliquées
la conséquence pour vous c'est que vous
devrez être capable de synthétiser et de
simplifier
l'idée essentielle de la citation ça
vous permettra ensuite de trouver le
problème intellectuel à résoudre dans la
dissertation
troisième chose que vous devez retenir à
propos des sujets il ya une phrase qui
est là pour vous guider
mais elle ne sert à rien par exemple sur
le sujet de polytechnique younès de 2020
c'était vous commenterez discuterez ce
propos en vous appuyant sur des exemples
précis emprunté notamment aux héros du
programme
il n'y a aucune consigne précise dans
cette phrase et c'était pareil à mines
ponts et à centrale il n'y a qu'au ccp
que la phrase invite le candidat a
critiqué l'affirmation de l'auteur de la
citation donc la troisième chose que
vous devez retenir c'est que la phrase
de consigne qui accompagne la citation
de ses rares et concentrez-vous donc
exclusivement
sur la citation voilà pour les sujets il
est temps de parler des notes je vais
vous donner les statistiques
essentielles pour l'épreuve de
polytechnique jeunesse pour celle des
mines ponts pour celle de central et
pour celles des ccp
on commence par l'épreuve de
polytechnique hoeness pour résumer la
moyenne était autour de 10 en 2019 un
peu supérieure à 10 en 2018 est encore
autour de 10 en 2010 est donc grosso
modo c'est autour de 10 ces dernières
années notez que la moyenne de la
filière pc et 0,5 à 0,75 point inférieur
en synthèse pour l'épreuve polytechnique
younès les moyennes tournent autour de
10 alors que la barre d'admissibilité
est entre 12 et 13 concernant
mines-ponts maintenant les statistiques
ne sont malheureusement pas ou plus
disponibles concernant l'épreuve de
centrales la moyenne était grosso modo
entre 9 et 10 en 2020
presque 10 ennemis en 2019 sauf pour la
filière thé s ils ont la moyenne était
neuf et demi et enfin c'était la même
chose en 2018
sauf pour la filière thé si dans la
moyenne était à 2,9 donc les moyennes
font entre 9 et 10
alors que les barre d'admissibilité sont
selon les écoles entre 10 et 13
concernant les ccp enfin les moyennes de
l'épreuve était ces dernières années
entre neuf et demi et dix et demi et
comme il y à plus de 30 écoles dans ce
concours commun et bien il y a plein de
barre d'admissibilité différentes
vous trouverez celles qui vous
intéressent sur internet voilà je vous
ai donné les statistiques essentielles
qu'est ce que vous devez en retenir pour
préparer l'épreuve de dissertation
français vous devez d'abord retenir que
ce n'est pas compliqué d'avoir 10 le
gros des copies se situe entre 9 et 10
ou bien autour de 10 donc vous pourrez
atteindre ses notes sans être
particulièrement bien préparée seconde
chose que vous devez retenir des
statistiques c'est que si vous
ambitionnez l'admissibilité aux boys et
aux très bonnes écoles alors vous devez
vous
et au moins 13 et là vous ne pouvez pas
négliger votre préparation
si vous visez plus de 13 si vous voulez
sortir du ventre mou des copies alors
vous avez besoin d'une méthodologie
solide comme celle qu'il ya dans mon
cours gratuits par email c'est une
méthodologie que j'ai conçu pour être
solide mais aussi simple je vous
conseille donc de vous inscrire à mon
cours gratuits de méthodologie de la cie
certes à sion soit en cliquant sur le
lien qui apparaît maintenant en haut à
droite de la vidéo soit en cliquant sur
celui qui est dans la description de
cette vidéo
allez c'est l'heure de conclure alors
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez retenir de
cette vidéo pour faire simple retenait
trois choses première chose
les correcteurs veulent que vous rédigez
une véritable dissertation et vous devez
donner l'impression que vous connaissez
les oeuvres au programme dans le détail
deuxième chose les sujets seront des
citations longue et compliquée donc vous
devrez être capable de synthétiser et de
simplifier l'idée essentielle de la
citation troisième et dernière chose il
sera facile s'il entre guillemets
d'atteindre 10 mais vous devez viser 13
pour être admissible aux meilleures
écoles et encore une fois la clé pour
réussir cette dissertation de france s
et netto dolo j voilà voilà
j'espère que cette vidéo vous sera utile
je suis romain je suis toujours avec mon
fidèle aristote qui dort là bas ils vous
étiez sur milliers de culture générale
rappelez vous vous n'avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête pour réussir la
dissertation de france est en prépa
scientifique
[Musique]